hallo Friede hallo Robin ihr studiert
hier an der Uni Götting also ich mache
ein Praktikum hier im barfekam
tatsächlich gerade wisst wisst ihr warum
was da los ist eigentlich ich habe keine
Ahnung barff kann man mittlerweile
online beantragen deswegen schaue ich
mir jetzt mal eins dieser Hyper modernen
barfäter
an aber zur Sicherheit bringe ich
trotzdem noch mal ein Drucker mit und
ein stapelpier man weiß ja
nie
Herr schwabero sie sind
hauptsachbearbeiter hier im barfückamt
und ich bin erstmal positiv überrascht
sie haben ja ein Computer
jawohl wie man sieht haben wir auch
mittlerweile zwei Bildschirme pro
Arbeitsplatz ich dreh durch um das
Material was die studieren und
zuschicken dann später auch besser
sichten zu können man kann doch Barf
digital beantragen wieso ist denn dann
hier noch so viel Papier das ist richtig
genau der der der wirk bis eigentlich
e-ak ist noch weit viele
Bundesländer arbeiten mit
unterschiedlichen Betriebssystemen was
das anbelangt die Kopplung untereinander
funktioniert da noch nicht so gut also
wenn ich jetzt Barf beantrage beantrage
ich das digital das ja schon mal top
dann kommt das hier digital an genau was
passiert
dann wie viel Seiten werden denn jetzt
hier so pro Tag gedruckt so als
Vorstellung 2 500 Packs also 1000 pro
Tag pro Tag heißt über 300.000 pro Jahr
eine Fichte gibt über 100.000 Blatt 120
000 Blatt das heißt drei
Fichten sterben pro Jahr wegen
mangelnder Digitalisierung nur bei uns
wie lange hatten das bei euch eigentlich
gedauert vom Ausfüllen des Antrags bis
zu dem Zeitpunkt wo dann das Geld
endlich auf dem Konto war also ich habe
bisher noch nie vor November dieses Jahr
wird's dann erst wohl januar oder so
Geld bekommen wie viel Monate dann jetzt
halt vier Monate ja das muss man dann
halt erstmal vorstrecken können aber das
ist doch scheiße also ich meine wenn man
jetzt also Studierender ist und eben man
beantragt ja Barf man das Geld ja nicht
hat und das ist doch bestimmt für viele
dann auch ein echtes Problem oder ja
also ich habe jetzt quasi das Glück dass
ich nebenbei arbeite aber jetzt hat das
Bundesinnenministerium doch so ein
tollen Satz rausgehauen ich möchte mal
vorlesen ich kann das gar nicht glauben
dass das alles nicht klappt weil die
sagen
zusätzlich zu der vereinfachten
Beantragung erhalten antragsstellerinen
und Antragssteller nun schneller eine
Antwort und auch die Ämter sparen Zeit
bei der Bearbeitung der Anträge das
stimmt nicht ne nein natürlich nicht
nein es ist im Augenblick unheimlich
umständlich zeitaufwendig so dass wir
Sprechzeiten einschränken mussen dass
wir telefontage festlegen müssen weil
unsere Leute sonst nicht arbeiten können
es ist wirklich an der Belastungsgrenze
der Kolleginnen und Kollegen und
tatsächlich hat der Bundesrechnungshof
das auch als irreführende Information
kritisiert weil es tatsächlich stimmt
halt nicht ihr beschwert euch wisst ihr
was ich da für ein Knochenjob habe ich
bin den ganzen Tag am ausdrucken ich bin
den ganzen Tag am Stempeln Post
verschicken könnte man alles
automatisieren okay und jetzt die
E-Mails die du ausgedruckt hast die ich
dir hier mitgebracht habe muss du
natürlich den Akten zus das sind jetzt
nicht alle Studierenden und ich muss das
jetzt in die Akte der studieren er genau
das wir du tun also
bitte wow wow wow ich zeige dir den
ersten Namen das gibt's doch nicht und
suchck mir bitte die passende
Akte noch mal zur Erinnerung dieser
Vorgang gilt laut Innenministerium
bereits als digitalisiert der Antrag
wurde ja online gestellt sie sehen also
ein Sortieralgorithmus der neuesten
Generation mich euer BF wurde bewilligt
also erstmal herzlich Glückwunsch muss
man auch erstmal schaffen wie wie ist
das gelaufen ja also man kann ja online
so einen Antrag stellen da wird man auch
relativ gut durchgeführt tatsächlich ist
es online einfacher als auf Papierform
damals aber ich fin es halt schwierig
man hat nachher überall ein grünen Haken
dass man alles eingereicht hat und dann
kriegt man halt doch wieder Post dass
noch was fehlt und man denkt sich so
aber ich hatte doch eigentlich alles
richtig ausgefüllt nur einer von 200
Anträgen ist
korrekt woran liegt das sind die
Studenten so doof also ich denke für
viele ist es einfach noch kompliziert es
auszufüllen es vollständig auszufüllen
viicht liest man sich die Hinweise nicht
ganz durch oder denkt sich das
kreäuzchen ist gar nicht wichtig aber
gerade das eine Kreuz das ist für uns
wichtig und dann schicken wir es auch
gerne per Post wieder an den
Studierenden zurück das muss ja noch mal
ausgedruckt werden ne es wird dann noch
mal ausgedruckt oder kopiert je nachdem
viele Bäume müssen sterben weil viele
Sachen ja eben auch umsonst ausgedruckt
werden weil die Studierenden leider
nicht nur E-Mails schicken und nicht nur
Post sondern eben auch bfolk digital
nutzen und wahlweise alle drei Sachen
auf einmal das heißt hier kommen die
Anträge mehrfach an dass nim wiederit
das nimmt unsere Zeit auch in Anspruch
weil wir ja dann abgleichen müssen und
das machen Studierende wahrscheinlich
auch deshalb weil sie einfach auch Panik
haben weil sie Angst haben es kommt
nicht an die Angst ist groß und deswegen
schickt man un eben manchmal auch per
Fax also Elternteile nutzen auch gerne
noch ein Telefax na ja es wird halt auch
nicht irgendwie direkt bei einem anderen
Amt dann angefragt was verdienen die
Eltern denn sondern es wird halt die
Papierlage gesichtet also ja könnte man
halt ein bisschen Form schöner den
Prozess machen gerade digital das kommt
zwei etwas schon digital rein aber bei
uns das meiste geht eben per Papier raus
aber das nimmt ja wahnsinnig viel Zeit
in Anspruch oder genau wir haben extra
Kolleginnen an der Poststelle die eben
die eingehenden E-Mails auf die
Sachbearbeiter verteilen und eben
ausdrucken und stempeln auch das
Stempeln auch noch also was wir in
Deutschland ja brauchen werden ja
eigentlich so ausgebildete Informatiker
und italer um die Digitalisierung mal
voranzubringen aber ich glaube die
warten alle noch auf ihren barfkantrag
oder gut möglich
Deutschland hat die Digitalisierung
radikal
verpennt der Föderalismus steht sich an
der Stelle selbst in Weg statt dass der
Bund einfach vorgibt ihr habt die
Software zu nehmen wie ihr sie dann
implementiert ist eure Sache das heißt
ja es gibt vier Softwar Lösungen in
Deutschland vi verschiedene die nicht
miteinander kommunizieren wenn ich jetzt
in einem Bundesland studiere und dann in
dem anderen heißt das dann passiert was
dann wird die Akte
per Post hierher geschickt das heißt
Bachelor in Köln Master in Götting und
es wird die Akte per Papier bewegt
Wahnsinn
Wahnsinn als Deutscher Boomer habe ich
von Digitalisierung natürlich keine
Ahnung ich hole mir gleich doppelte
Expertise zum einen Fabian denn der ist
der einzige beim ZDF der weiß was tiktok
ist und dieser Professor aus Österreich
der absurderweise seit über 20 Jahren in
Deutschland lebt ist das nicht auch ein
Gefühl von Stabilität und Beständigkeit
dass sich seitdem im Bereich
Digitalisierung so wenig verändert hat
hier man muss die Bereiche unterscheiden
also wenn man Industrie ansieht wenn man
Kreditwirtschaft ansieht da läuft es
halt im gleichen Tempo wie überall auf
der Welt dafür sorgt der
Wettbewerbsdruck wenn man sich die
verwaltungsdigitalisierung
ansieht dann läuft heute anders anders
heißt ich denke dass wir da den
Anschluss verloren
haben aber wie kann denn das sein ich
meine Deutschland war doch auch mal
Vorreiter es ist nicht sogar einer der
ersten Computer aus Deutschland ja die
berühmten zusmaschinen aus den 40er
Jahen ja na ja das kann eigentlich
relativ einfach sein in anderen Staaten
hat man die Signatur an die
elektronische Identifikation gekoppelt
und den Bürgern gratis zur Verfügung
gestellt ich habe auf meinem Smartphone
die österreichische handysignatur drauf
ich kann wenn ich will mich den ganzen
Tag hinsetzen 3000 Dokumente signieren
und bezahl dafür nichts in Deutschland
kostet das was dann gehen sie doch
zurück nach Österreich sie ange beruhig
dich beruhig dich mal ich könnte nicht
nur zurück nach Österreich gehen ich
könnte z.B auch nach Moldau gehen dort
funktioniert das genauso aber warum
warum ist das hier so also gute Frage
echt gut ich denke es liegt an zwei
harten Faktoren der eine ist Geld die
Italiener haben die verpflichtende
e-Rechnungen nicht deswegen eingeführt
weil sie digital sein wollten sondern
schlicht das Geld gebraucht haben und
die Steuern deswegen haben die se 204
verpflichtende eRechnung der zweite ist
ich brauch halt ein klaren politischen
Willen schwierig ja ich habe Hoffnung
dass ich jetzt in Bezug auf die
Digitalisierung was verändert in
Deutschland wirklich ja es gibt Bedarf
Einsparungen zu realisieren und es
werden mit guter Digitalisierung viele
und hohe Einsparungen
möglich sind in Deutschland nur
zuversichtlich weil Deutschland am Ende
dazu gezwungen sein wird es zu machen
nicht weil irgendjemand Bock drauf hat
sie gucken sich auch manchmal in den
Spiegel eigentlich könnte dich Abnehmen
wirklich machen uns es nur dann wenn es
an der Arzt sagt betrifft eher mich
jetzt muss man sagen okay also du bist
die personifizierte deutsche
digitalisiert ich lass mir gerne
vorsagen ich bin zu dick aber das geht
so weit mein Freund Entschuldigung wir
brechen ja ab okay
okay wer das ganze Spezial mit uns sehen
will der klickt einfach hier drauf und
weitere Videos von der heuthow die
gibt's hier ja ich glaube es ist ehrlich
gesagt genau umgekehrt nee kannst du mir
vertrauen wenn ich das sage dann ist das
so mein ich glaube ehrlich gesagt das
ist
umgekehrt